environmentalists frequently make a
nuisance of themselves they throw soup
on beautiful paintings they force us to
use those stupid paper straws that turn
to Mush halfway through your drink
and on Friday they took things further
than usual when the British group just
stopped oil blocked a mother from taking
her baby to the hospital
[Music]
see the mother arguing with
[Applause]
got my baby in the car moved
gotta go to the hospital move they don't
move this guy this complete
glass-eyed dude walking like a zombie
with all these other
radical environmentalists just saying no
no they're just going to keep blocking
traffic even if it means a little baby
can't make it to the hospital Even If it
threatens the baby's life it's not even
the environmentalists can they just walk
like zombies like they don't
they've surrendered some deep aspect of
their Humanity
walking around like lunatics
[Applause]
okay you get the point
if it would not have slowed her down
that is if this woman would not have
been almost immediately arrested she
obviously should have just run them over
she at the very least should have just
love tapped them until they moved or
fell but she should have just run him
over when hippies crimes threatened the
life of one's baby the just action is as
clear as day
and just as clear is the left's
anti-human agenda the whole scene is
just another reminder that at every
single turn the left will prioritize
anything and everything over real living
breathing people
they will prioritize the convenience of
the mother
over the life of little babies the
convenience the free the autonomy of the
mother over the life of little babies
they will prioritize the supposed
comfort in reality
just the suppression of health care
costs by the way but the supposed
comfort
of people over the lives of the elderly
and the sick and the homeless killed by
euthanasia
they will prioritize the rocks and the
trees and the Delta smelt and if I want
to be as charitable as I possibly can to
these guys they will prioritize the idea
of humanity in the abstract Generations
from now over a living breathing baby in
a car who we can only hope and pray is
still living and breathing no thanks at
all to the supposedly humanitarian
liberals Marching In the Streets I'm
Michael knowlesis the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
back to the show in just a moment why we
should disband a U.S women's soccer
we'll get to that just a moment first
though
I don't want to move on from stupid
environmentalism just yet because I saw
it's my favorite CNN Headline ever
it's my favorite one it's my favorite
story it's not just CNN here
it's a it's a liberal proposal more
broadly here's the headline
giant kites could pull cargo ships
across the ocean
and slash their carbon emissions
now it if you're watching right now you
can see the picture of this but if
you're not just maybe close your eyes
picture what this would look like giant
kites
pulling ships
you may have seen kite Surfers in action
harnessing the power of the wind to pull
them over the sea now imagine try to
imagine this the same concept applied to
a one thousand square meter kite flying
300 meters above the water only instead
of towing a surfer across the waves it's
helping to propel a colossal cargo ship
across the ocean well that's the basic
idea behind the Sea Wing a technology
being developed is being developed now
this is obviously in the very early
stages being developed by French company
air Seas which it says could help cargo
ships reduce their fuel consumption and
cut their carbon emissions by an average
of 20 percent
the Liberals have just discovered the
concept
of sailboats
sailboats
were invented in 4000 BC
at least
sailboats have been around
for at least
six thousand years in the libs
just exasperated in their excitement
they say we've got it we've got the
answer to environmentalism instead of
having a ship powered by I don't know
oiled or cold or something like that
what we're gonna do we're gonna we're
gonna fix this big thing to it what do
we call it's like a kite but is there
another word could we call it yeah like
a sale and the sale is going to propel
the boat and what we could call it
we could call it a sailboat the libs
love
Reinventing normal things
and making them Dumber this is something
I've observed about the lids from for
many years this is just the most recent
example of it
and the libs in the 60s they did they
decided
they were going to have these new forms
of living man they were going to live
like it's like a commune man and but
they're all going to work together you
know on the commune and so like one
person man they're gonna bake the bread
you know and the other man they're gonna
like teach the kids you know and someone
else on this new age of Aquarius kind of
commune living man they're gonna Farm
the food man and Oh you mean like a town
you're gonna you're gonna live in a town
no man no man it's way cooler and
[Applause]
one relatively new and they'll say what
we need we need mindfulness
do you we're just so wrapped up in our
days we need what we need to do is stop
all of our business and all of our
distractions we're gonna sit we're going
to kind of close our eyes and we're just
gonna we're just gonna be mindful and
we're gonna say things in our heads
you get like prayer you're going to pray
well no man prayer is stodgy and old and
conservative we're gonna we're just
gonna say things in our heads that
articulate our desires and our our
gratitude and our adoration
it's different in that mindfulness it's
just when you pray to yourself you just
worship yourself instead of prayer is
when you pray to God but okay yeah it's
called it's called prayer it's been
around for a while
even gender ideology by the way
don't worry I think we can keep this one
on YouTube I think this one's allowed to
stay on YouTube I'm not I'm just I'm
actually saying a nice thing about
gender ideology the best part of gender
ideology is finally for the first time
in a very long time the Liberals
admitted that the soul exists
that's the best part that's the silver
lining in the storm cloud of gender
ideology is that the Liberals finally
admitted for the first time in a long
time that we're not just bags of meat
that we're not just our biology that
there's something else to us
now we
traditionally call this the soul
that's what pretty much everyone for all
of human history everywhere has called
it but now we call it the Gen this is my
gender identity or my true self or
whatever they want to call it but they
just take
basic normal things about life and they
make them Dumber like our new like the
new kite affixed cargo ship
formerly known as a sailboat when things
get really dumb and stupid in the world
sometimes the economy can falter and
when economy start to vulture you don't
want to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to the US Dollars Global
dominance in the past 80 years on August
22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia India
China South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is
right now when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold as an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers text Knowles Canada wlas
298 98 98 get your free info kit on gold
if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it will be nice to
have some gold to depend upon text
Knowles Kendall wlas to 98 98 98.
speaking of the libs misunderstanding
things and also having a blatant
disregard for human life
there's a story I bet you saw this go
around the news or at least social media
over the weekend a Nebraska teenager
a poor young girl was jailed for having
an abortion you said it couldn't happen
here we're living in the handmaid's tale
this girl went to jail for an abortion
allegedly according to David Frum David
from who's not just some crazy live
David Frum was a speechwriter for George
W bush David Frum for a long time was
considered a leading conservative
intellectual he's now probably
considered a little bit more liberal but
many people would still call him on the
center right David Frum tweets out they
swore up and down they wouldn't send
girls and women to prisons for abortions
they lied
Brian Cohen who is a liberal he's been
on I think he's been on this show before
I've been on TV with him before at least
Brian Cohen tweeted out uh quote
a Nebraska teenager has been sentenced
to jail and charged as a felon after
ending her pregnancy with abortion pills
she faces up to five years in prison
this teen
was not sent oh no I'm sorry this is
what the the community note says I love
Community notes Community notes it's
probably the best feature that Elon has
brought back and really built up during
his tenure at Twitter the community
notes Here on Brian Cohen's post says
the teen was not sentenced for having a
chemically induced abortion during her
third trimester but for burning burying
and concealing a dead body so she wasn't
charged even though she had a a an
abortion she murdered her child in the
third trimester if you've never seen a
an ultrasound of what a baby looks like
in the third trimester do it just looks
like any Ordinary Baby in this teenage
girl murdered her baby who looks just
like any other baby that you'd see in
newborn
that's not what she was sentenced for
she was sentenced to 90 days in prison
not all that long
not for murdering her precious little
child which she did but for disposing of
this Baby's dead body in a way that
desecrated the body and tried to set on
fire and all sorts of crazy stuff not
only is the girl going to prison for 90
days
the girl's mother faces potentially up
to five years in prison because the
mother 42 years old helped the girl do
it helped the girl bury the body just
like any Street criminal I mean really
bad street criminal any mafioso any
mobster who says here come on over here
will help you bury the bodies out here
in Las Vegas yeah you go through the
deserted bodies buried everywhere that
kind of stuff this is what the mother
has done
abortion in Nebraska is not totally
banned should be but isn't you can kill
your baby in Nebraska up to 12 weeks
up to a third of the pregnancy
this girl did it at 28 weeks this baby
could have lived outside the womb she
could have just induced labor
given birth to this baby put the baby up
for adoption she never would have had to
think about it again she wouldn't have
been inconvenienced for one single
solitary second she chose instead to
murder her child and she wasn't even put
in jail for that
she was put in jail for what
this is the Crux of it all
the reason that the libs have to lie
about this story the reason this law is
actually very instructive
maybe in some places you'll hear people
calling for punishments of people for
having abortions that's not the
mainstream pro-life position it's
punished the abortionist it's punished
people for burning and desecrating a
body say but but not for
even having an illegal abortion not not
for the mother to do that but but this
was very instructive in that
it reminds you
there is a body
whose body is it it's the baby's body
why do the libs have to lie about this
story because if you read about what
happened here you recognize that the
baby is a baby if the baby were just a
clump of cells
you wouldn't have to bury it
or you wouldn't have to try to destroy
the body to hide it from people all of
whom can recognize just looking with
their own two eyes this is a little baby
sometimes people say about Richard Nixon
he didn't he didn't commit the crime of
the Watergate break-in what he was
guilty of is the cover-up
well that's what we're seeing here the
crime is the cover-up because the
cover-up is a particularly ghastly thing
where you're where you're hacking up a
body like and like the most Stone Cold
psycho you can imagine Jeffrey Dahmer
kind of stuff
and they know that when people hear that
story they're going to to not only side
with the justice system here at the very
least it's probably lenient but they're
going to turn on abortion they're going
to turn toward the cause of life and so
these Libs have to lie about it speaking
of women's issues
the U.S women's soccer team
[Music]
apparently had a game over the weekend
I'm not the biggest fan can't say I've
ever watched even 30 seconds of a US
Women's soccer game but during the
national anthem a significant portion of
the team decided not to put their hands
over their hearts but to stand somberly
hands behind their back disrespecting
the Star-Spangled Banner
you go one girl puts her hand on her
heart good disrespectful well they don't
even teach the kids to do it there's
another girl okay there's another girl
has her hand on her heart the rest of
the vast majority of the team another
one
at least two to one they're
disrespecting the flag not putting their
hand on their heart
standing stoically they're not willing
to
they're not willing to take the knee
that got all that kind of trouble in the
NFL
okay there we go there's one guy
with his hand on his heart
it's at least half the girls are not
doing us we're a little more than half
the girls
no hand on their heart
so it's a subtler form of disrespect
than the Colin Kaepernick stuff and then
you can see because you could tell this
was a political problem the cameras
started zooming in on the girls who do
have their hands on their Hearth but you
can't ignore it it's just so clear so
many of them are not doing this why are
they not doing it are they not doing it
because they were brought up the wrong
way like those little kid they've got
these little kids standing in front of
the women's soccer team they don't have
their hands on their heart I don't blame
the kids for that the kids were just
brought up the wrong way their parents
didn't teach them how they're supposed
to stand for the The Star Spangled
Banner
the adults should know better and
furthermore I'm skeptical that this is
just some innocent mistake one because
they're they're teammates have their
hands on their hearts so they're
noticing that this is what one does
and two because U.S women's soccer has
historically been extremely left-wing
and unpatriotic I think of that awful
woman Megan rapino as the poster child
of this
and because in sports broadly there has
been this this Rebellion Against The
Star Spangled Banner and the flag which
symbolizes the whole country so what are
we to do about this
what I would be inclined to do at the
very least is fire those women who
disrespect the flag from the team just
fire them out right
and potentially what I would do because
this has been a problem in U.S women's
soccer for so long is just disband the
team just get rid of it
and maybe you think that's a little bit
harsh but then let me ask you this
question what's the point of U.S women's
soccer
what's the point
is it to get a lot of viewership it
doesn't get that much viewership okay
it's not as bad as the WNBA but it
doesn't get a lot of viewership
but even if it were a really popular
team
that's not the point that's not what
it's for the point of a U.S national
team is to represent the U.S Nation
and so if the team
disrespects the nation that it exists to
represent then the team does not fulfill
its main purpose and should you should
just disband it and you can either start
again or just not have one no one's
going to miss the US Women's Soccer Team
so just get rid of it
if the salt loses its savor
wherewith shall it be salted what is the
point of the salt no then it's good for
nothing
and ought to be trampled underfoot
we have forgotten in the Modern Age not
just on the left but even many people on
the right that things have a purpose
a thing is defined in fact by its
purpose
you to use the some of the more formal
language some of the Aristotelian
language you are not
you as a person are not defined by
merely by your purpose like in the way
that the leftist ears tumbler is defined
by bringing delicious leftist tears into
my mouth that's what it's for if it can
no longer do that then it has no purpose
it's lost its Essence you're a little
different than that because you're a
primary substance and you're made by God
you're not an artifact made by man but
at the very least these things that are
just man-made constructs they have a
purpose they're defined by that if they
don't fulfill that
then get rid of it we have such Mission
drift such Mission creep in in all of
these man-made institutions now do you
remember during the Obama Administration
we were told that the point of NASA was
to make peace with the Muslim World NASA
NASA the thing that exists to go to the
moon and to go to outer space and to
take pictures of the stars we said no
actually the real purpose is to make
friends with the Muslim world
that's it the real the real purpose of
the US Army is to make people feel
really good about their gender identity
or whatever
no that's not no if a point of the US
Army is to kill people okay it's not
it's not too it's not to really come to
recognize white rage and correct the
deep-seated oppression of the patriarchy
of the no the point of the US Army is to
kill our enemies that's the point of it
if we're not doing that or if we're
putting the cart before the horse then
we need to structurally change that
and until there are consequences for
this kind of mission creep and in the
case of the U.S women's soccer team
undermining the very totally undermining
the very purpose of the thing until
there are consequences and someone goes
in there and says no we Define things by
their purpose and when they contradict
that purpose we cut it out
when when we in a phrase
stop pretending that freedom quote
unquote is an end unto itself
and start to remember that freedom is a
means to human flourishing that freedom
I'm now I'm just channeling the founding
fathers and all great Statesmen in
history that freedom is the right to do
what we ought to do that end in sight
not merely the ability to do whatever we
want to amuse ourselves until we die
we're not going to be able to fix these
problems until we recognize that Liberty
in America
is an instrument for the purpose of
attaining the blessings of liberty there
it is it's right there in our
constitution until we recognize that
we're going to continue to put the cart
before the horse and things are going to
become even more and more absurd now
speaking of cars when you want to buy a
car you got to check out karzing right
now go to carzing.com Knowles buying a
new car can be a stressful experience
for anyone especially if you're a first
time buyer or have no credit before you
walk into a dealership and spend the
whole day with crowds and stress and the
potential not even to find the right car
you've got to check out carsing carsing
is completely changing the way you buy a
car online by partnering with Credit
Agencies lenders and over 25 000 dealers
Nationwide karzing provides you with
everything you need before stepping foot
onto a dealership once you find the
right car at your ideal budget all
you've got to do is bring your saved
deal voucher with you to the dealership
to finalize your next ride it is super
simple even if you are not in the market
for a new car you should check out
Carson anyway Carson's online shopping
experience goes beyond mirror images you
can dive deep into each vehicle's specs
features performance capabilities zoom
in on the craftsmanship of the Interior
Marvel at Cutting Edge technology admire
what sets these cars away from the rest
carsing helps make your experience
faster cheaper and less stressful
carsing.com head on over there today
find the best deals near you carson.com
Knowles
those environmentalists
they drive me crazy especially when they
stop women from
taking their little babies to the
hospital well aren't you sick of them
they'll tell you to ride a bicycle while
they fly in private jets they'll insist
that you stop eating meat because of
methane or something but they'll happily
Chow Down on their juicy fancy steaks
and Davos I bet you do a much better job
of conserving the environment than say
John Kerry or Saint Greta sent great of
the Blessed sailor board
especially
if you get Jeremy's new green tea and
citrus hand soap you probably didn't
know where that commercial was coming
for a while uh yeah I certainly didn't
well
here it is
it's free of parabens sulfates
it's also free of Dei and ESG and bad
and LMNOP for that matter
it's not tested on animals
it's made right here in the US of a that
means that you can feel patriotic and
Superior at the same time so do yourself
a favor wash your hands of hypocritical
lives once and for all go to
jeremy'srazors.com order your green tea
and citrus hand soap
today
speaking of national politics and ladies
Lauren bobert my friend Lauren bobert is
calling for the impeachment of Joe Biden
Lauren says we promise to uncover Joe
Biden's corrupt business deals that is
exactly what we have done Jim Banks and
other great Conservative Republican in
Congress he he said the same thing he
said quote most corrupt family ever to
live in the White House and Peach why is
that
why are they calling for Biden's
impeachment right now you know
Republicans are always calling for
Biden's impeachment well it's because
the house oversight committee has
released an FBI form an fd-1023
that is from an FBI informant
that alleges
and explains how uh Joe Biden was
involved in personally in a five million
dollar bribery scheme with a barisma
executive that was released by the house
oversight committee and Chuck Grassley
so overall that means this Ukrainian
oligarch paid the bidens Hunter and Joe
10 million bucks in exchange for the
sale of American influence
so should we impeach Joe Biden we've
been talking about this since before the
man took office since he was just
elected
or at the very least
claimed to be prepared to be installed
as the President of the United States
anyway uh should now be the time I have
been one of the most consistent voices
opposed to impeaching Biden for
impeachment's sake
and I've got two two good words to
explain why we shouldn't impeach Joe
Biden those words are Kamala Harris but
also because
I I felt we didn't have a good predicate
for it
impeachment as
some of us observed during the Trump
impeachments is not merely a political
act but it's also a legal act it has a
legal requirement to it you have to have
plausibly committed High crimes and
misdemeanors to have impeachment brought
and then you have a trial and then
you're convicted or you're not convicted
the legal basis is now there
if the Joe Biden payoff scheme for which
there is such ample evidence we've got
terabytes of data from Hunter Biden's
laptop that include texts that include
emails that include photos okay we've
got videos You couldn't possibly have
more evidence against these guys
and we've got Joe Biden on tape saying
that he threatened to withhold a billion
dollars in usaid to Ukraine unless they
fired the prosecutor that was looking
into his son is the company that his son
was working for the company that
allegedly paid 10 million bucks for the
buds we've just got so much evidence for
this if this isn't public corruption I
don't know what is now this was
corruption that the bidens allegedly
engaged and while Joe was vice president
okay fine it's still
if this is not a high crime or
misdemeanor I don't know what is
now the other argument against
impeachment was well what are we going
to do we're just going to impeach
everybody the one party's always going
to impeach the other party when he's in
office that's going to lead to a
breakdown in our political system yeah I
guess so
and Republicans have contributed to some
degree to that but the Democrats really
started it the the Democrats started
this with Nixon at the presidential
level the Democrats started this
weakening of our ordinary political
systems with with the torpedoing of
Judge bork during the Reagan
Administration and so the Dem started it
we've played the game too we impeached
Bill Clinton but the Democrats then
impeached Joe Donald Trump I think 150
times they've impeached him so far and
they're going to keep impeaching them
now they're they're trying to uh
indict him after he's left office and if
he wins election again you know they're
going to impeach him about 700 more
times
so
even beyond that the Democrats are
attacking people for being conservative
they're sicking the FBI on people for
being pro-life and protesting outside of
planned parenthoods they're sending the
FBI to go spy on Catholic churches the
ones that are particularly conservative
they're now in Michigan you're seeing
people who question the 2020 election
now being brought up on charges okay
you're obviously seeing trumping brought
up on charges for this so This goes a
step further this is not just the
Democrats wielding political power to be
harsher to their enemies than to their
friends this is the Democrats
criminalizing conservative politics to
say nothing of the censorship to say
nothing of the ostracism and the
professional consequences that come from
being ordinarily a conservative so if
the Democrats are going to criminalize
conservative political action we just
have no choice I don't want the libs to
be able to call our shots and decide who
we nominate for office and decide how we
act but in war and in politics your
enemy has a say and you have to react in
real time this was what the never
trumpers didn't understand this is what
the squishes to this day don't
understand
is they want to live in a time that no
longer exists so they say well why can't
politics be like it was back in the 90s
or something why can't politics be like
it used to be when I was a kid when I
have these memories of politics working
better because it's not that's why
that's why and back when we had I love
Bob Dole but back when we had Bob Dole
back when we had John McCain as a
nominee back we had Mitt Romney as a
nominee they lost
and they lost in part because of the
weakness of their positions and they
lost in part because the Democrats were
playing a different game and playing a
much harsher game and we don't want to
engage in that harsher game we don't
want to wield impeachment as freely as
the liberals do but they've been doing
this for a long time they've been doing
this since Nixon
and either we're going to play that game
or we're just going to concede and we're
going to lose in a supposedly dignified
way that I don't think has any dignity
at all so I'm with Lauren I'm with Jim
the time is now to impeach Joe Biden
I'm as slow on it as anybody
the time my friends has come speaking of
Joe Biden's legal problems
if this doesn't sum it up I don't know
what does
Hunter Biden was visiting his lawyer
Hollywood lawyer Kevin Morris and
they're in Hollywood you know Hunters
hanging out in in either Malibu or the
Palisades right now with who knows what
people and substances and he's he's
making his doodle paintings he sells for
half a million dollars a piece to
launder money to the Biden family so
that's that's just the corruption that's
out in the open by the way well Hunter
decides to visit his lawyer because he
does have legal problems and the lawyer
Kevin Morris was photographed on his
balcony while Hunter was visiting
ripping a bomb
I'm not even knocking the guy for
puffing the devil's lettuce the sin
spinach the Peruvian parsley
I would knock him for it but that's not
even
it's how Brazen it is
it's how Brazen you've got Hunter Biden
here Hunter Biden's in your home you
know he's under media scrutiny you know
there's so much evidence of public
corruption and you just say yeah screw
it who cares what are you going to do to
us what are you stupid peasants going to
do to us what are you conservatives
going to do what are you Republicans
going to do you're not going to do
nothing
yeah yeah you've seen hours of Hunter
Biden committing all sorts of crimes on
video yeah whatever you're not going to
do anything now hold on while I rip from
this bong
some people are saying look this is
evidence that Hunter hasn't cleaned up
his Hunter cleaned up I don't know uh I
would be surprised but it'd be nice you
can hope and pray that he's cleaned up
actually the fact that Hunter's lawyer
went out onto the balcony to rip the
bong while Hunter was over is pretty
good evidence that Hunter wasn't ripping
the bond because otherwise they'd just
be they'd be doing drugs together in the
room so okay that's
obvious charitable as I can't 100 by and
that maybe Hunter wasn't wasn't puffing
on the sin spinach himself
but what this is also evidence of is
that Hunter is not taking this
investigation seriously he's got some
pothead dope of a lawyer he's just
banging around a Hollywood ripping bong
hits while they're supposed to be in a
meeting of that legal strategy because
they know that the guy's not going to
face any consequences they know that you
can get Hunter Biden basically dead to
rights taking bribes demanding bribes
not paying taxes having shakedowns all
around the world to say nothing of the
drug and sex crimes and what are they
going to give brandishing weapons left
and right what are they going to get him
on they're going to get him on two
misdemeanor tax crimes and a diversion
program for the weapon
meaning he'll face no days in jail
the weapons charge will be expunged from
his record it's just nothing so yeah
whatever who cares Hunter could hire a
Charlie day to be his lawyer
it doesn't matter you don't need a real
lawyer
blinds get away with whatever they want
and Republicans if you ever object to it
you're going to jail now speaking of
presidential Politics on our side
new poll from Harvard Harris
shows really good news for Vivek
ramaswamy tough news for the number two
candidate Ron DeSantis
really good news for Trump trump is now
up according to this Harvard Harris poll
Trump is up 40 points Trump is at 52.
DeSantis 12 percent
the baked ramaswamy 10 so in a
statistical tie
Pence shockingly still holding
relatively strong at seven percent
after the Tucker drubbing then it's kind
of surprising though perhaps so this was
July 19th through the 20th so I guess
this actually should take into account
the Tucker drubbing and Penn's still
holding strong at seven Haley it for Tim
Scott's down there at two has not taken
off Chris Christie holding on with this
too
uh the rest of the guys you know down
one or two percent now what happens if
it's just Trump versus DeSantis just the
top two guys
Trump's lead drops a little bit but his
numbers obviously improve because you're
taking so many candidates out of the
race so Trump at 63 DeSantis at 37 so
it's 20 points 26 Point swing that is
from Harvard Harris which is a respected
poll
what does this mean
it means that the bank is taking points
from DeSantis
it means that I think all these other
guys are taking points from DeSantis but
the vague in particular is growing
because vivek's campaign is
throwing spaghetti at the wall and
trying out new stuff and getting kind of
weird and Taking Chances and all the
other campaigns are playing it safe and
as all the other campaigns play it safe
the the number two campaign that has to
has to take shots at Trump if it wants
to go anywhere
is going to diminish Trump is basically
going to benefit he can play it safe
because no one's taken points from him
and the other candidates remain where
they are
DeSantis in the baker in different
circumstances so I don't mean to be too
harsh to the Santa's campaign here the
vague can play nice with Trump because
if they came from nowhere so he can play
nice with Trump not irritate the Trump
voters Maybe
be kind of nice to Trump voters in a way
that the DeSantis campaign has not
succeeded at doing yet
maybe they're trying but they haven't
succeeded at sweet talking the Trump
voters away from Trump to DeSantis
and so Vivek can take most of his shots
against DeSantis that's in his political
interest to do and it's it's effective
it's easier to do than taking shots at
Trump
the DeSantis campaign has a very
difficult task ahead of it and it has
had this task from the beginning so they
I hope they went into this with their
eyes wide open which is they need to
attack Donald Trump without attacking
Trump's voters
but they can kind of play all around the
field because he came out of nowhere and
he's not the number two guy yet but
DeSantis the strong was the clear number
two guy his only person that he can take
shots at is Trump and he's got to win
over a huge number of trump voters who
are unusually loyal to their candidate
and so he's got to attack Trump while
still sweet talking the voters can he do
that
he hasn't done it yet
this is increasingly hard because the
Trump voters are not moving to DeSantis
so there's going to be an Impulse among
the DeSantis supporters maybe not even
among the official top tier of the
campaign but among the middle and lower
tiers of the campaign to start going
after those Trump voters that will be
death
to the DeSantis campaign I'm not saying
it's easy I'm not knocking them because
they're not succeeding at it right now
but they've got to figure it out because
otherwise there's a shot that DeSantis
forget about might not overtake Trump is
number one he might not even remain
number two if they don't
make a hard pivot on the campaign right
now as I have been encouraging them to
do for a long time I speak the truth and
love my friends it's because of I like
Ron DeSantis and I have a number of
friends on his campaign they've got to
make a pivot or else you could be
looking at Vivek ramaswamy as the number
two guy now speaking of learning things
when you want to learn you got to check
out Hillsdale College right now head on
over to hillsdale.edu Knowles are you a
few years or maybe decades out of school
and wondering what the heck did I even
learn and what was the point you might
think to yourself that you don't have
time to learn something new if that's
you then know this you're not alone it's
not too late since 1844 Hillsdale
College has been providing education in
faith freedom and character they have
taken some of the core classes that they
teach on campus and made them available
for free online for anyone who wants to
learn that is right for free there are
39 free courses to choose from ranging
from the U.S Constitution the Book of
Genesis to free market economics they
are easy to follow their self-paced so
you can start whenever you want in fact
you can start right now it's everything
you need all in one place no long-term
commitment go to Hillsdale College let
them be your guide go to hillsdale.edu
Knowles to enroll no cost easy to get
started hillsdale.edu Knowles to
register
hillsdale.edu Knowles
my favorite comment
on Friday is from Shaz westable
who says the best thing you have ever
done
was your interview with Jacob janslay
the human on Shaman I applaud you
eternally that seriously took you out of
your comfort zone you nailed it oh thank
you so much it's getting really nice
responses uh this was my two and a half
hour interview with the Q Anon Shaman
you can get most of the interview on
YouTube if you want the full uncensored
interview there were there were some
moments we had to take out because of
big Tech rules where they would have
killed the whole channel so you get that
at Daily wire plus you get it at emnol's
show on Twitter this is the first long
sit-down interview that the Q Anon
Shaman has had since getting out of
prison he was in prison for 41 months
and the conversation was all over the
place and uh
you know
Jacob's views I he doesn't like this
term but I I think it's pretty safe to
say the very new age and so uh you know
I tried in our discussion to point out
what the difference is between his views
and say a Christian view would be or a
traditional view or conservative view
but mostly I mean the purpose of those
long interviews the Michael Anne series
is
I just find these people fascinating and
few few people that you've ever come
across are more fascinating than Jacob
chansley so I I just wanted that to be
an opportunity to learn about who this
guy is and I I think is a really
interesting Japanese very different
than the media would have him portrayed
so really go go check it out if you
haven't already
speaking of
Trump
the date is set for one of the Trump
trials I guess we've got to be specific
now because there's so many trials
because the libs are trying to throw
this guy into Gulag for the rest of his
life a federal judge Aileen Cannon has
said that the Trump classified documents
trial will start May 20th 2024. in
Florida in a swing state could you
imagine you're a Hollywood scriptwriter
could you write
a more compelling storyline you've got
the general election in November of
2024. the trial for Trump whether or not
they're going to throw him in prison
starts May 20th 2024 not just about will
we upend centuries of precedent in jail
a former president jail the leader of
the opposition but will
will a man
win the presidency from a jail cell will
oh my good can you imagine and in
Florida a big swing state though even
now it's kind of just a Republican state
why is it in May of 2024 the AP is
reporting AP is a far left outlet but I
think they're probably right about this
that the date was seen as a compromise
between a request from prosecutors to
set the trial for this December they
really wanted to speed it up
presumably to try to kill Trump's
nomination and a request from defense
lawyers to schedule it after the
presidential election which would seem
to make a lot more sense but this The
Narrative demands this gripping this
gripping date
and frankly if I were the Trump defense
team and especially if I were the Trump
campaign team
I'd be happy with it I think basically
this is good for the GOP I think this is
good for Trump
Trump maybe won't be the nominee but as
of now
a Gambling Man would say that Trump will
be the nominee
his numbers are
extraordinarily dominant and they're
only either staying the same or getting
better
this will I think this trial will
fire up the base
obviously if you if you think that this
election is really about whether or not
we're going to see the leader of the
opposition party the leader of our party
we the base uh go to prison for the rest
of his life I think that's going to fire
you up and just the way in 2016 the open
Supreme Court seat from Justice Scalia
motivated the base yeah okay so you get
the base out there and a lot of
presidential elections are just about
motivating your own people but
furthermore I think that this trial will
persuade moderates and Independence and
Centrist people to come over to the
Republican and Trump side
assuming Trump's the nominee
the Democrats believe that it will push
moderates and centrists and Independence
to their side
because people aren't going to want to
vote for a criminal I don't think that's
how people are going to view it I think
the American people are a lot smarter
than that and they're going to see this
as it as it is as an unprecedented
political prosecution and persecution of
the leader of the opposition and I think
this is too far
you're seeing a populist conservative
movement among Ordinary People
for now some years in America in the UK
you're seeing it in Spain you're seeing
it in Hungary you're seeing Italy you're
seeing in Germany you've seen in Sweden
so this is not just a fluke you're
seeing the people kind of rise up and
say liberalism has gone too far you
obviously see it on a particular
ideology pertaining to human nature that
we're not allowed to talk about on big
Tech you know boys and girls and stuff
like that you're seeing Ordinary People
push back against that you're seeing the
pendulum swing I think moderates and
independents and centrists are going to
look at this if the Democrats do convict
Trump even if they just put them on
trial then the trial's been going on
that close to the election they're going
to say too far we're not going to reward
the Democrats for this maybe I'm too
Rosy about it but I just think
if it's going to cut one way or the
other I think this trial date Cuts in
the favor of trump and the Republicans
speaking of politicians on trial
and things that I can't say on YouTube
which is why you got to watch the show
at Daily wire plus and Twitter and on
the RSS feed
the nation's first ever
first ever
[Music]
this is not merely some academic
conversation that we're all batting
around in in a faculty Lounge this is
are we going to protect the most
vulnerable people in the country or not
and are we even allowed to raise the
prospect or even talk about these
people's crimes
on the main Platforms in the Public
Square as of right now mostly
you cannot and that's a big political
problem
and until the Republicans and the
conservatives wield their political
power to do something about it
it's probably not going to get better
now
we've got so much more to say
I've got so many more
things to talk about
not on YouTube
but we can't the rest of the show
continues now we've run out of time on
the main show if you are just a member
of the Hoy polloi out there then you've
got to join the member Block You've got
to come over for the member of segmentum
you've got to increase your prestige
become a member of the head on over to
dailywire.com also check out for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh
foreign